das ist
OS am liebsten zockt er und wenn er
nicht zockt dann guckt er Game One mit
S ja und der ist bei klickum zu Gast
nicht nur weil er MTV Game One moderiert
nein er ist ja auch in der Jury des
webvidepreises darüber möchte ich mit
ihm reden und natürlich eure
nutzerfragen sind wieder dran lasst euch
was einfallen les den Infotext hier
unten und lade die Fragen am besten als
videoofrag hoch der Link ist hier direkt
im Video ja und dann kann eigentlich
fast nichts mehr schiefgehen wenn es
nicht wieder dutzende sind dann fällt
uns die Auswahl natürlich schwer aber
umso kreativer ihr seid umso besser sind
die Chancen viel
Glück